hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is our you garbage I am your host H
Foley coming at you from beautiful
Astoria Queens on this beautiful sunny
day my co-host
however is coming from an undisclosed
location somewhere in southern New
Jersey this guy's on the run from the
corona kevin james ryan everybody hey
what's up guys thanks for tuning in
happy to be here survived another day
down here in the bunker you know um
thanks for tuning in everybody obviously
real quick please rate review subscribe
share with a friend all that bull all
that good [ __ ] take care of it help us
out we appreciate all the support so far
yeah happy to be here very nice and we
have an extremely special guest today as
well also for the closer for the Cova i
don't think we would have got her now
she is not just a prominent stand-up
comedian she is also a best-selling
author and really a [ __ ] trailblazer
in the podcasting world
she's totally slumming it right now with
me and Kevin because she could probably
buy us and sell us like two cans of
[ __ ] beans ladies and gentlemen
Corinne Fisher everybody what a nation
that's how we do it you're killing it
buddy we're so happy to have you here we
appreciate you doing the podcast you
know good to have human contact I'm glad
we saved it for this yeah it could be
that much more intimate and special yes
how are you how are you holding up over
there with the but to lock down and all
that see I this question makes me so
uncomfortable because I'm literally
that's good the dudes I'm on the
borderline of that I've been preparing
for this for the last [ __ ] in two years
the only time I've been leaving the
house is to go do stand-up and then come
back and lay around and now everybody
else is doing that so the anxiety of not
doing stuff is completely going and
that's something like I always like I
just am always like going and so stress
out of time you know me you're always
get your Akane Club and I'm running it
off with a like a chicken with my head
cut off and like that's how I've been
living my life since I was in like the
seventh grade so it's very nice to have
this like forced quarantine where I can
just relax and like you only get two
things for my to-do list done every day
I'm like spend time with my dog in my
apartment that I worked for because like
I hadn't seen it so yeah and also like
I'm just very um influenced like
emotionally by other people's energy so
I realized during this already you know
it's only been like two weeks how like
how much of a negative impact other
people's energy has on me like it's so
it's so bad I feel so [ __ ] energized
like anytime I have an interaction with
other people even like a small one which
I know most people are like yearning for
during this time it's always bad like
yesterday I was [ __ ] walking my dog
and a jogger tailgated me and I'm like
the city is empty you dumb [ __ ] yeah
what are you doing yeah that's terrible
we're down I've done in South Jersey at
my family's short lake beach house like
you're like Marlborough whatever you
know even further south I'm all the way
down in mummy Wildwood New Jersey many
weeks in wild but as a shot yeah so we
he we came I mean my wife came down for
the weekend
and then New York City shut down so
we're like I'm not [ __ ] going back so
we're hanging out down here I'm like
it's it's like a vacation you know what
I mean we're in this we're in a
three-bedroom house we have like a huge
kitchen we go on bike rides every day
the islands it's awesome so yeah we're
hanging out I thought I thought I was
missing human contact
like you know from outside cuz me and my
girl here but and I've never been one
like chitchat with people on the street
you know just [ __ ] whatever and I
went out for a smoke before we started
to do this and that wore off in about
two seconds this guy who's the super of
the next building block by as a
hey you doing yeah why you don't engage
for a second and it took it took about
three bounces of the conversations I was
like all right because just talking when
you start to talk to somebody and they
have a difference of opinion he's like
God he's like oh I don't know what Cuomo
was doing oh my god I think he's doing a
good job and just launches into a tirade
oh my god bunny be safe I hope you get
it get away from me the [ __ ] out of here
yeah that's why it's weird
I'd only I had the only like long
conversation I had with someone I didn't
know beside like podcasting and stuff
was in the dog park and but I actually
that's like the one place where I love
human interaction because the people in
the dog park who are willing to talk in
the dog park we all share this
commonality that we like dogs better
than humans though it's always these
kind of weird quirky interesting people
like I'm gonna sound designer who did
songs for me and rosebud Baker in the
dog park like I'm making business
connection it's great I love it yeah and
the woman I talked to you this week she
was like she was definitely like me if I
don't play my cards right and like you
know but I loved her energy she told me
about making four quiches and how the
dogs are taking over her apartment and I
was like I love this for you so that's
great
you probably meet people that are used
to talking to dogs more than humans at
the dog park so it's like you don't know
what kind of conversation you're gonna
[ __ ] get yeah I worry about going to
a pharmacy and I had a let her know that
the pharmacy or see a pharmacy will
deliver to you yeah exactly so if I see
a dog on the street I never talk to the
owner I always just talk to the dog and
I'll melt I'll melt the second I said I
never talk to the owner and I hate when
the owner Yanks the dog away like what
am i a [ __ ] pedophile
exactly a couple file I meet up that
word on Twitter I'm such a Papa file
I will walk down the street and just be
like hi doggie hi Donnie and I'll say hi
doggie out loud like someone who's not
all there you get annoyed when you walk
Alfred I'd only get people stopped you
know well they're gonna pay for that if
they if they stop because if any one
time someone leans down in to Alfred he
goes crazy and barks and I and I don't
warn them cuz he doesn't bite so I think
he's not gonna hurt them but he just has
a really vicious park for a little 17
pounds so I just let him I just let him
I I go oh sorry he's a little cranky
like I'm really I think it's called it
brings me great amusement that's great
yeah a little preview to the game we're
gonna start in a second here but just
out of curiosity just to mark something
off the list do you dress the dog up and
closed and take him for a walk other
than like if it's the middle of winter
um I was like I I had a colony in
Compton for him but other than that I
don't like he's a whippet mix so he
actually does need like a sweater or a
sweatshirt or shivers so and because I
was what was someone who was vehemently
against dog clothing but then I got this
dog and I was like oh like some dogs
like medically need to because they
should but yeah other than that no I
don't take him in like bumblebee
costumes on a Tuesday I got I got an
aunt who dresses the dog up for like st.
Patty's Day and [ __ ] I'm like lady you
need to get out of the house I'd like
some ice shirts or sweaters like around
the holidays or something like yeah I
don't have like a Christmas thing
whatever but like I'm not just putting
costumes on him I mean except for the
one time we put on like a cowboy outfit
and then needham dance private dancer we
got to get you out of the house kid
that's all my friend and I we we dressed
him up as a cowboy and then we threw
dollar bills at him
and made him dance the private dancer
that sounds like a good time now I'm not
gonna lie I would definitely I would
definitely partaken all right curry
Fisher you are definitely a stand-up
comedian of incredible note you've done
incredible things but we have to find
out are you garbage so we're gonna ask
you a series of questions we want you to
ask them to your best knowledge we know
a little bit about your background I
just want to talk about that for a
second that will jump right into it you
were born and raised in Union New Jersey
correct the record already drinking a
snap a diet Snapple the entire time
which is very you know what pisses me
off
I know I agree it's cold it's not as
clean yeah you did with you guys what am
i parents do is the question my mom is a
teacher a middle school teacher and my
dad owns a baseball card and horror
memorabilia collectible store whoa
that's [ __ ] awesome Wow in Jersey I
presume Indian Union yeah it's in
Roselle Park Wow
all right so like you grew up wasn't
like a single home suburbs you grew up
exactly yes okay did you have a
refrigerator in the garage no we did not
have a refrigerator in the garage I had
friends who did but we never did that's
cleaned up and you got if you got a
garage bridge that is [ __ ] I had one
growing up it's still the same one it's
that like white that's now yellow oh
it's [ __ ] that's great is that just
like for a like story extra like if you
want to froze the meats in there it's a
lot of the freezers always meats that no
one's ever gonna eat right they've been
in there it's like fish from 15 years
ago and it's mainly just sodas like
silly water yeah so does water beers ice
pops for the kids in the summer it's a
real garbage thing if you have a garage
fridge you're they're awesome but you're
garbage
Oh see this is good to know because I
always felt like oh are we poor because
we don't have
refrigerators the thing is a lot of
people think that it's oh we bought two
refrigerators the one was like and
uncles are like it was they set down
there on the side of the road
it's never we went out one day and
purchased two new refrigerators okay
okay but let's stay on the topic of
growing up a couple of questions about
the household growing up let's go into
the bathroom for a second what kind of
soap shampoo did your mom get we use
them like bars a dial did you have a
bottled shampoo or bottled soap well
when we first started we did do we had
bars of like it wasn't dial I think it
was like I like ivory or dove like a
little up that it wasn't the smelly kind
and then we went batty wash got like
cool we then elevated to like that and
Bodyworks it was different kind of like
smelly seasonal body washes I hope they
got acne as a kid so I was usually using
my own like Neutrogena like acne body
wash and then for shampoo everyone had
different shampoo like my dad would use
head and shoulders and my mom has curly
hair so she would use like some kind of
like a socially you know Bed Head
whatever and then I for a while I've got
really into using Johnson and Johnson no
no more tears but that's just because
it's actually really good for your hair
and it's actually better for dandruff
then head and shoulders I was like it
was a problem you had a lot of medicated
creams going on it sounds like a lot of
issues I always had like special stuff
for me I can't just use anything but oh
and Noxzema was very big bravissimo I
love that Zima like the way it feels
when you put on your face
yes it's like smoking that menthol
cigarette oh Allah I just loves the cool
refreshing feel of Noxzema yes what I do
remember when you said when body washes
got cool I remember when they dropped
and my mom brought them home for the
first time for like my sibling and I
thought we were the [ __ ] Rockefellers
I'm like this [ __ ] is great you smell
like fruit and berries and roses all was
amazing I'm like then they had like the
the foaming hand so we were we were real
garbage growing up we had coast soap and
the only shampoo that we owe so we only
share who we were allowed to get and I
still love it to this day was suave
strawberry that takes me back and we
used to think people in Herbal Essence
came out oh that was like [ __ ] caviar
to my household we got that like once
every six months when the [ __ ] when
the tax return came in yeah
what about in the kitchen what kind of
you know basic stuff did you use
Hellmann's mayonnaise use Miracle Whip
Hellmann's Miracle Whip I didn't even
know that it was until I was an adult
and I went out and I loved chemicals
like that's a neat thing and I went out
and bought it for myself it also has
like less calories and I was like very a
guy for a period of time I was very
obsessed with like diet foods before
Whole Foods not the rep not the grocery
stores whole eating whole in general
became what like we're supposed to do I
was like variant like sugar free diet
reduced fat you know child of the 80s
like get any chemicals you can to
replace nutrients in there so you see
were you a soda family growing up if so
Coke or Pepsi whatever was on sale is
the answer to that my died drink soda
every day like from the bottle like
straight from the bottle from the
garbage I love it
that's a lot but me and my brother my
brother or not my mom is a really likes
that much a little bit of the caffeine
free diet coke Oh cuz on top of the acne
in the dandruff I also had a terrible
bedwetting problem up until like age 12
me too me too
it was a bad real bad Disney World
at one time and like not sexually so but
yeah and it's my brother and I we had
like soda restrictions I love soda but
we were only allowed to drink soda if we
were eating Italian food or like why
Italian that's always a question we ask
and that's never an answer I've heard
before
Oh pasta without soda it just goes with
the marinara
it does it does the bubbles and the
carbs it all works together be crazy I
got a question the defense will Foley
did you guys ever drink milk for dinner
when you were growing up like have you
sat down with like pasta today would you
ever get a good glass of milk do you say
yes I was like no my mom said now is for
trash people actually we have every
likes milk with dinner it's the weirdest
[ __ ] thing to hold milk half the time
when you're like three months old you
should not be drinking whole milk unless
you're on keto yeah did I drink it all
that I dude there's nothing better than
an ice-cold glass of whole milk and I
shake it up before I drink it all not
really a month you'll drop like a 25
pounds like that's what I tell them I
said like you cut the soda in the whole
milk you'll be looking like [ __ ]
bread so easily with minor changes like
I lost a bunch of weight like maybe six
years ago five or six years ago at this
point and like I mean within the first
thing week I was like three belt sizes
down because I I didn't eat pizza and
soda every meal that's crazy
I lost 30 pounds like in the past two
years but it was based kind of on a mat
it would mostly on a medical condition
but like
work medication and doctors visits it
took me to lose I'm exhausted
I'm dating a guy he'll be like oh yeah I
want to trim up and then like three
weeks later he's down you know yeah
we're really fortunate we can lose it
really quick it's crazy
mm-hmm all right I got another one about
childhood and while we're while we're in
the kitchen still as you will wha mac
and cheese was it Velveeta or Kraft
neither my mom made it from scratch holy
[ __ ] hi homemade magic cheese use your
mom Martha Stewart I don't even know you
could make it at home until I was like
32 yeah my mom likes you she likes like
the crunchy top the bait kind of like a
recipe like there's like multiple kinds
of cheeses and you're stirring and there
you're eating milk and all this kind of
stuff yeah that's beautiful thing yeah
you guys ever do any any Hickory Farms
baskets or Omaha Steaks
get that delivered no we are not a huge
my mom is not a huge meat-eater my no
one in my family actually is like a huge
huge carnivore like we would have steak
or pork chops every now and again I was
always a very like minimal meat-eater
and I don't eat meat anymore at all now
um but yeah that was frozen there was
never any frozen meats that's good
that's it frozen meats is a telltale
sign that things aren't you know things
aren't always going so hot every day
before I leave for school there would be
a frozen XP every morning a nice glass
of milk and you know Gordon's [ __ ]
fish sticks
no every everyday we would leave for
school before we'd leave for school my
mom would take some sort of meat out of
the freezer and it would sit in the sink
all day so it could be frost terrible
that's so bad
live I got him on which I realized that
I didn't realize miss trashy until I got
older did your did your mom ever used to
make shake and bake chicken yeah get me
her get me started over here come on
well shaking a chicken man what the a
mice my mom never made it and then my
parent said the words my stepmom started
making it and I went back to my mom like
yo cooks you gotta [ __ ] get this bag
what I'm sorry what about Hamburger
Helper no we didn't do that we didn't
your ton of box food I was a shake and
bake we did and definitely we just shake
and bake with stovetop stuffing from the
canister which I I still to this day
will get forget and make it for myself
cause it's so [ __ ] good
I think it's way better than regular
stuffing and everyone my buddy you give
me a little let me give me a little
stovetop you can keep the turkey I'll
tell you that right now a bull's-eye I
have like in college and I would just
eat a bowl of stovetop stuffing for
dinner it's it's I don't know what
they're putting in there and I probably
like holy [ __ ] great so this is uh this
is tough so far I'm getting a lot of
mixed signals here there's some pros
there's some cons entire now let's step
it up and not I think you just by far
this is the furthest one that we're not
sure yet usually I'm like with other
people is like the first question we
were like oh you're [ __ ] trash but we
did have Jared freed who is not garbage
but his dad kind of was but that could
still be like old-school Jewish dad vibe
you know what I mean that could have
been I was mostly I was like that's also
why it might be difficult to tell with
me because my parent my mom is a
Christian my dad is Jewish and so Jews
tend to not be trash but then we will do
a couple things yeah yes yes yes exactly
exactly did your parents both growing up
my chain-smoked since he was like 12 my
mom never smoked now did you ever this
is from from one of our listeners gutter
sloth wrote in and wanted to know did
you ever go to the store as a kid and
buy cigarettes for your for a parent no
no okay I think that [ __ ] that's
probably more your generation for it I
mean I think me and Corinne are the same
age so it's like we were so many
cigarettes there was already some laws
in place for [ __ ] you couldn't this
wasn't the 1930s I remember me and my
buddy Rodney Klein in order for us to
get money from his mom or my mom to go
to the little deli we'd have to we'd
have to get to the pack of smokes and
we'd go in no questions asked
couple packs of bench and hedges couple
packs of marble lights and a couple
[ __ ] Kit Kats and we were on our way
oh my god that's terrible you will you
guys a bumper sticker family garbage no
my mom was like bring home like
absolutely not only garbage sunshine
like my aggressiveness up like 20% and
that's like my mom on a good that's
awesome that's [ __ ] great I love it
until you come home as a good kid like
mom I want this on the car she's like
get the [ __ ] out of here garbage people
we're not doing that that's great I
think it's a good point anything you do
as a anything a kid thinks is cool on a
car isn't gonna be you shouldn't do as
an adult you know what I mean right
like it's like mom this would be so cool
in our car but like we're definitely not
[ __ ] doing that because you're seven
I mean yeah I'm like you know
Kalvin pissing on hobbes or whatever
yeah yeah anything pro-american is some
sometimes because my dad's a veteran and
sometimes his bumper stickers go a
little too far he's got one he's got one
that says four had one I made him taking
off the car it said if you can if you
can read this take a teacher if you can
read it in English thank a veteran I was
like buddy
what do you look at your car I don't
know your job was Donald Trump what
about golf only I just I got I got two
things and then one thing just the rapid
childhood have you ever been to any of
the following as a family and they were
going to a yard sale or have you ever
gone to an air show I've never been to
an air show I've been to a big city art
skills and had garage sales but not as a
whole family just like my mom and I and
my brother my dad was like running store
so he never came
so partial family outing see our show
sorry say that again
it wasn't like to buy suffer so I just
found them fascinating and like more so
we would have them then go to them
because my mom would like to get rid of
stuff stuff yeah yeah but you wouldn't
permit in my town to have them like you
I mean maybe every town but like you
kind of like yeah you hadn't have a
permit to have a yard I think everyone
is supposed to but people most people
just don't I never even heard of that
that's not me not in the 80s I'll tell
you that we were playing it fast and
loose on Saturday yeah in a running game
I got another one head did you ever go
to the New Jersey State Fair we loved
fairs I've been to Fleming amusement
mini amusement park yes okay it feels
like
there's our [ __ ] trash we used to go
to the Pennsylvania State Fair every
year for like two weeks and we were so
trashy that we knew like we had a hookup
we knew a guy that like sold the meat to
the vendors I don't even know we had
like we would get like free funnel cake
and like you know we would be free
tickets and was [ __ ] traffic but so
it was like my mom like definitely like
like when you like you know watch out
for the carnies or whatever do it she we
look like I we love like rides and
newsmen parks and like that kind of
thing we I do that I love it to this day
but yeah I love it
during the summer I'm like where we're
going like the pop-up ones and like the
parking lots and stuff oh they were the
lights the funnel if they're so good and
it was also like when you could go you
would go with your parents and then you
were like old enough to like oh we're
gonna go if you were like 12 or 13 or
whatever you're like oh we're gonna go
do our own thing and then like come and
you were like free rein and a carnival
as a young teenager forget about it I
just think you're like eating a candy
apple just having it like all over my
[ __ ] face and I the games you could
win life as a kid you could win like a
knife or like a you know you wouldn't
cool [ __ ] as a kid they're like at 12 or
13 year old kid wanted you know you get
like fireworks or something
I used to women I have I have an old
like print like just like printed out of
a printer picture of the Spice Girls
friend and like a baller frame and I
want it like doing the rollerball racing
worst thing and I was so [ __ ] wow
that's just jogged my memory those
picture frames the those dollar all
thank God they were huge
so definitely unauthorized license bro
yeah you got the on say to come down
here to sign this what I wanted to
backtrack uncle Hank I am a big fan to
this day of the candied apple so that I
ever had one and see people caramel
apple or something around Halloween but
like to me a candy apple is so far
superior to any other type of
that you can get because you can still
get it like down the shore like wild
water point pleasant and those beautiful
like tacky candy shops some of them are
still open now there's like the only
thing that's open there's like one pizza
place and a saltwater taffy fudge place
I love that Point Pleasant boardwalk and
just eat like four days it's great
saltwater taffy is garbage but it is the
[ __ ] greatest thing ever he said I
love banana saltwater taffy I like
banana Laffy Taffy that's a that's was a
big toy when I was a kid huge fan tip I
you got anything to wrap up the
childhood here I do as a teenager did
you ever spend significant time hanging
out like a 7-eleven or a gas station or
any convenience store um there was a
quick check that popped up but when I
was probably in like late middle school
or high school that people would hang
out in the parking lot I didn't hang out
in the parking lot a ton but I did we
would make like frequent trips there
yeah and then like when I was younger
there was a Cumberland Farms and that
was like the first place I was allowed
to walk by myself like to do a big girl
like trip alone I think I was going to
like the frickin mall you know I you're
making reservations very very adult but
yeah so but yeah we didn't love you know
we did love getting like a butter roll
or like a sandwich from quickcheck that
was it the suburbs as a teenage like
there's not much to do so it's like
everybody would like me that we would
there was a gas station that we would
just hang out and would you know you're
just skateboarding or whatever trying to
have people buy his cigarettes that type
of [ __ ] for us it was just we went we
went to the diner we went bowling or
then in high school we realized we all
learned how to play pool and went to
this billiards hall because we're like
oh this is like better than bowling this
is like a little bit classier hanging
out the pool hall as a young girl real
[Laughter]
I really like pool like to this day I
enjoy playing pool is better than than
bowling bowling is [ __ ] garbage and I
know people that had birthday parties at
a bowling alley and I was like send my
RSVP I burped that was like one of the
hot like skating rink and bowling alley
were two of the hottest birthday party's
waiting rent was huge yeah it was great
pizza at a skating rink I don't know
what what Michelin star chef
they had working but my [ __ ] skating
rink this guy could put out a slice like
nobody's [ __ ] business I agree with
you well like I was in Girl Scouts I
merely slept over on the floor of the
skating rink that was like a popular
trip like you'd bring your sleeping bag
Wow
but like to get back to bowling like as
a middle-class suburban Jew bowling is a
big part of our culture so like my dad
and my cousins are like extremely good
bowlers and like my parents actually
both had their own bowling balls and
grazed with the bag they would go
bowling frequently and like my cousins
were on like the bowling team at our
local high school like yeah it was like
a big thing I think I think there's a
passage in the Old Testament about Moses
rolling a 300 somewhere that's how he
figured that's how he beat the 710 split
be part of the Red Sea's and hit a 7
that's good I got why got just two more
about about growing up one did you ever
work in a mall stay on the teenager tip
um I did not until I was in college but
I worked at Victoria's Secret
but it was in a very very nice small
like Victoria's Secret was by far the
trashiest store in the mall because it
was at UM Short Hills Mall if I know if
you are familiar with that New Jersey
it's like a really like all the stories
like Versace Gucci like like celebrities
will come in from New York City to shop
there because we have the you know No
taxes on clothing in New Jersey seal
stands but yeah so I did work at the
mall but it was like a very fancy mall
and my last question about your
childhood is did you ever twirl or eat
your hair as a young girl I twirled my
hair and sucked my fingers so much that
when you put my hair down it was this
high and one part was this because I
twirled this one so much that it didn't
even grow like it was several inches
shorter on this side cuz I twirled and I
sucked
I didn't suck my thumb I suck these two
fingers and I would like this oh my god
my brother 12 his hair until he was in
high school the back of his head he
would twirl this hair like that all the
time I didn't know that garbage thing I
was like an anxiety disorder yes coping
mechanism I think that's an indication
of your family's values at all I sucked
my thumb until probably sixth grade Wow
yeah yeah I loved it it was great I
never got into it but that's just her
she's German they're into weird [ __ ] you
know all right I got one more from back
when you were younger did your parents
ever put you on a leash um I oh I mean I
not like a dog I know what you mean like
those like child's play ball or
Disneyland or Six Flags absolutely yes
they did watch yeah it was like a belt
it was a belt it wasn't I didn't have
the harness on my body
it was Mel croelick on the wrist yeah
and then there was like a like a
plasticy swirly thing just so we didn't
guess it was I don't know like dude
those were again very popular when I was
a kid and it was like a because I know I
grew up in that
where it was like don't talk to
strangers your neighbors gonna [ __ ]
molest you the guy across the street
wants to give you a you know like it's
like a very scary
ya know I remember we had one too I
remember my mom we never used it but I
think I don't know if there was one at
the house but the same thing it was like
the wristband with the curly no like
thing that would be on like a surfboard
type thing yeah and because they like in
the 90s I was very like we became aware
that like oh people are [ __ ] wacky
and they're gonna steal your kids and
stuff yeah I had a whole song that my
mom taught me like if I get abducted so
that I could remember my address and
phone number to tell to like the police
like we would do like little drills of
like where to meet if something happens
like who to go to like we had an escape
plan like it was not me 80
not me eighties kids we play it was
[ __ ] free-for-all back then you got
to a van that was on you ask questions
idiot what are you doing jeez that's
terrible right II moving right along
have you ever have you ever dated
anybody that wore khakis to a wedding
um god I don't I don't I've never been
with I've never gone to a wedding with
anyone I was dating honestly anybody in
your family ever wear khakis still
wedding no I don't think so
yeah that's a big red flag with me
that's trash
there's always one guy at the [ __ ]
wedding that's wearing a pair of khakis
or cargo pants near like the [ __ ] it's
black tie what are you doing yeah no
he's like a full suit Ellie I need to my
dad or my brother like I've gone to
weddings with my dad my brother like
anyone I've gone have had full suit on
we went to a comedian friend moms at
Monroe Martin's wedding and there was in
[ __ ] Jordan full matching Jordan
tracksuit and the comics were [ __ ]
destroyed I mean the whole time we just
laughed at
it was his that poor bastard got made
fun of for three hours straight that's
awesome
all right I got one did you as like a
teenager did you ever steal makeup from
the store no I've never stolen anything
in my entire life wow that was that was
big that's girls steal I'm like
guarantee I'm I'm very I don't know I
have like a weird like moral like list
of morals for myself
and I've always been like very against
stealing it just like bothers me a lot I
don't know same way yeah yeah I hate it
when people when I know friends of ours
that like you know like 1 2 7 11 it was
still like a candy bar and I'm always
like do you really want to be the guy
that got picked up for stealing a
[ __ ] Snickers bar yeah I hate that
[ __ ] they go through heavy drinking
klepto fees but I wasn't stealing like I
would steal like a fork from my my own
like place setting at a restaurant like
that good I did that like I have to go
fork and a knife like maybe from like a
and but they weren't expensive they were
like really cheap used cutlery I don't
know I just used to get your anything
that was funny but like I've never
stolen anything like with a price tag on
it from any store if we go up to dinner
we go out to dinner somewhere and like
say like the glass we have a drinking is
like really really cute or like
something really really nice I'm like my
girlfriend will mention like oh it's so
cute I'll always try to be like romantic
and I'll steal it at some point and hide
it in my pocket and then and then give
it to her later like a present that's
garbage
that's cool I was gonna say we do the
same thing I remember the one time I had
a cooling me your glass or losing a mug
or something I'm like oh this is cool I
was awesome yeah my girl was like oh
this is cool I would like to get
something like this for the house and
she just took it important to our um I
have a couple to broader questions
number one what would you say if you
have one is your trashiest snack that
you like that something that you love
that maybe like doesn't go together but
you find it super comforting and you
have it all the time even as an adult
like for
me would be I love peanut butter and
jelly and bread and butter pickles
together I don't know why you put the
bread and butter pickles on the sandwich
or just eat them on the side I eat them
on the side with a glass of milk and
peanut butter and peanut butter and
jelly and potato chips I know that's
trashy I think I had peanut butter and
jelly with bread and butter pickles
literally during this quarantine because
I have bread and butter pickles in my
fridge right now and a lot I definitely
had peanut butter and jelly I mean I
don't see one look on the cup no nut and
very sour no but like oh yeah don't
trashiest snack what do you think I mean
I just like something that if you told
people they'd be like what the [ __ ]
she's eating that well I think my
favorite trashy like meal it's more like
a meal is this thing called noodles and
cheese that my mom made and it's real
trashy basically it's like it's like
those thick egg noodles that you buy in
the bag at the sea and yeah mix it in a
big bowl a big pot with just a [ __ ] ton
of butter and cottage cheese you know
and my mom was like this is like a this
is like a Great Depression yeah sure
what the [ __ ] we got garbage here look
out cottage cheese egg noodles and
butter it's warm yeah it's like it's a
it's a guy it's like macaroni and cheese
but they're just a different take on it
I'm telling you I'm drying it because
I'm a I'm a big I know it's garbage I'm
a big cottage cheese guy [ __ ] God really
but when it's when it's worms and notes
a little on the noodles with the butter
it is really really good Russian style
mac and cheese
I love egg noodles still we used to get
to when I was a kid we'd have at all
time to dry
she would always [ __ ] a little butter
hmm
man
all right I got I think I got one or two
more here for ya
did you ever date a guy who sold weed
yes that's all I was what age was it I
mean pretty recently what about a guy
who wrote a motorcycle you ever date you
buddy that wrote a motorcycle and you
wrote on the back of it no I've actually
never ridden on a motorcycle and that's
one of my my biggest regrets in life I
hate to vary it seems like something I
would have done in someone I would have
dated I dated a lot of people who seem
like they should have motorcycles but
none of them actually did Wow you ever
owned any ed hardy stuff you ever were
an Ed Hardy t-shirt uh yeah because that
was really hot I have one at a hardy
t-shirt I I think I think I didn't even
give it up because I was like so proud
of it had King Kong on it like a long
tunic style one but again like that was
like if you didn't have an Marti when I
when you were in high school
at my age like you were you were not my
what else I think to think about that
just not just jog my memory the Von
Dutch hat remember those things on Dutch
hats like when you know simple life was
very cool in like the early 2000 yeah
the simple life I used to love that show
but they were on a farm or something
right there was something like that they
would do different things like they were
they work different things because there
was different seasons of it too but like
I that was one of the first major
reality TV shows that horns like jumped
off and I to this day like did you watch
that movie on Netflix American meme I
did I watched some of it yeah but I'm a
big fan of pH if that's where you're
going yeah it reminded me how much I
love to cars open and how much she
impacted like my you oh yeah I mean she
was the Kim Kardashian and you know I
mean she was the forefront of all media
for teenagers at that time yeah
yeah it's great all right I think I got
one more here oh this was big growing up
did you have blacklight posters in your
room no drug users but I did like like
them but I didn't have any like drug
paraphernalia and like the kind of music
I was in I was very into pop music so
that kind of went along with like more
like idea and like bands that I would
get into later mm-hmm I used to have
them we would have black lights I was
like you know I don't know 9 or
something and with like black I would
just go in my room and like like with
black lights on my mom must've been like
what the [ __ ] is he doing
you know from sponsors a little disco
ball that was like in my ceiling you
know what else was big - for us the
stars on the ceiling did you have a lot
because like my ceiling was painted but
I had like a ton of like posters from
like Spice Girls blink when I need to
Cruel Intentions like I had all those
posters in my bedroom like fun attack to
the wall that was big big my final my
final thing here is can you name the top
five things that gross you out better
deal breakers on all fronts with you top
5 things to curse you out Kevin's I
think one would be cottage cheese so use
that as an example oh you don't mean
like in a partner I just mean what you
mean in life yeah just an anything yeah
yeah yeah come on I don't even
this is something that people do the
crochet out well yeah okay so people
like people who don't wash their hands
when they go to the bathroom and I have
obsessive-compulsive disorder so I watch
that like that's why I'm like oh I'm
thriving in this quarantine like I
already washed my hands this much I know
that's what I'm paranoid about germs to
begin with so I'm like this ever the
rest of the world's just catching up to
me I was I've been training for this for
the past 10 years yeah I washed my hands
so well that multiple times in public
restrooms
people have turned to me and go are you
a nurse and I go no I just have always
just crazy just crazy
do you surgery so yeah people who don't
wash their hands when they go to the
bathroom um I'm really grossed out by
people who have like dirty teeth like
even if that's like even if it's
something like medically wrong with you
like fix it fix that check it now oh my
gosh yeah I would remember like if you
guys had [ __ ] up teeth and I wouldn't
have said that yeah what's up T is like
I can't like that's the thing like I can
kiss someone with like I don't love
dirty fingernails but like that's I'm
not like the deal breaker but like if
you look gross teeth like I can't make
out if you like your teeth are gross
stop it stop I don't like when people
win like couples um go to the bathroom
in front of one another
that's no for me I don't like that like
it's that's weird
even just p.m. yeah we need you need a
there needs to be boundaries it's like
it's like Yankee Stadium we're on that
right now
[Laughter]
like a friend like me I've definitely
peed in front Christina um yeah I don't
I don't love I just like I'll I'm really
big on boundaries they like [ __ ] love
like I don't even I've never lived with
someone and I never intended like a
romantic partner and I never intend on
it so I think I want to get married and
live in a different apartment from my
husband that has always been my dream
for many many years we'll probably make
it last longer for sure well I just
wanna I want to live like either in the
same apartment building on it like the
same street or like want you know within
10 minute walking distance or yeah I
need my own space it's very important to
me
Rose meow when people put gum under
tables
we're like when you just stick your gum
under something that's guilty never even
thought in my entire life to do it like
I would just just swallow it like what
are you doing I don't get I've been
swallowing gum forever that's garbage if
the choice is I can I have to run on
stage or something in the choices put
under a table or swallow it I swallow I
usually do how they can old receipt or
piece of paper or like old gum wrapper
that I can put it in but if I don't I'm
just gonna swap I'm gonna we were always
told that you could choke on it like
that was like that shear was putting
there once at a young age never swallow
your gum you'll choke no joke and I
don't know it only looks have you been
swallowing everything else in sight so I
think a piece of [ __ ] Trident isn't
gonna kill you okay oh it's too funny
tipping you got anything else that's it
for me
Curran Fisher I'm gonna say you're all
class buddy you're all class I take
class with an asterisk maybe the cottage
cheese kind of put it over the top for
me well it's funny I dated a lot of
white trash people so it's like I kind
of like appreciate the culture of being
trash I have a very white trash palette
that's what this whole things about we
just we realize that it's like growing
up it's like the things you enjoyed the
most were like doing these trashy things
with your family or the fact you like oh
I love that my mom used to make
Depression style you know Mac you eat
like the trashiness is and the more we
do this everybody's like oh that is the
best part of you know like it tastes the
best it's the most fun and just like you
know you gotta live a little of course
of course
very true Corinne thank you so much is
there anything that you want to plug do
you want to throw out there oh yeah I
mean I'm so you can listen to I have a
couple podcast guys we [ __ ] the anti
slut-shaming podcast with Christina
force that's like the og that is on the
ark like six and a half years of the
archive is on iTunes but now we are
exclusive to luminary if you guys are
gonna check that out and then I have a
brand new podcast with Joe DeRosa
that I'm really excited about called
without a country where we tackle the
most controversial news stories of the
week from the perspective of the extreme
right and the extreme left it's really
fun Joe gets mad a lot I flirt with him
and make everyone uncomfortable
come on philanthropy gal at on all
social media so give me a follow
sometimes I post pictures of my ass is
that trashy probably not at all buddy
I'm gonna say I always want to tell you
this I'm off everything you're killing
it what you're doing is unbelievable we
really appreciate you coming on and
talking with this thank you so much
Kippy you got anything no just go to my
website for all live dates for the next
three months over the country you know
things are booming no guys just a please
rate review share with a friend you know
we just started so help us push it we
appreciate all the support so far so
thanks guys yeah Corinth thank you so
much yes good idea good rest a day and
be safe okay you you too nice talking to
you
[Music]